friday was a strange news day and one of
the strange developments a comment from
the district attorney in johnson county
kansas who said that chief's receiver
tyree kill is not the subject of an
active criminal investigation involving
potential allegations of child abuse
regarding his three-year-old son that
has prompted many to assume incorrectly
that the case is closed that tyree kill
will be back nfl network tom pellicero
was on there friday saying no reason to
believe that hill won't be present with
the team when training camp opens but
not so fast folks the nfl told me friday
night that the nfl wasn't delaying and
still isn't delaying the tyree kill
personal conduct policy investigation
because of a possible criminal
investigation they've been holding it
all up and still are because of the
child protective services proceeding
that resulted in the child the
three-year-old son of tyreek hill being
removed from his and his fiancee's
custody so the nfl is still watching and
waiting the nfl is still not going to
authorize tyreek hill to return and
chris the nfl is still going to look
into possible personal conduct policy
violations unrelated to whether or not
tyree kill broke his three-year-old
son's arm i know that's the big headline
that everyone thinks if there's evidence
of that then obviously he should never
play in the nfl again if there's no
evidence of it then let him play right
now without further delay it's far more
complicated than that yeah and i know
that fans are very zealous and i know
they want to support their team but
folks folks look and i know this isn't
all chiefs fans but you got to put that
bag down right you got to focus on
what's right and what's wrong and if
this guy violated the personal conduct
policy with the threats that he made we
heard his voice right and jimmy smith
the ravens cornerback last year was
suspended for making threats not for
physical violence there are personal
conduct policy violations that
potentially occurred that the nfl will
investigate chris and just because the
d.a isn't criminally investigating tyree
kill it does not mean he's in the clear
it does not mean the nfl will allow him
to come back for training no no we know
that i mean maybe this helps his case as
far as right now to be
uh to have a suspension lessened maybe
you know he was looking at eight games
and maybe now it's four games because it
doesn't look like they're gonna be able
to pin anything criminally against them
this is where i ask you mike okay you
know the comment you know he makes to to
espanol you know as far as um uh
you should be scared of me too right is
that enough of a threat mike in your
eyes that i want to ask you that part
and then two what about okay we know the
the the baby boy the young boy the
three-year-old broke his arm we know
it's either tyrique or uh you know his
former you know uh what what's the damn
word i'm looking for they were engaged
what's that word beyonce
thank you it's monday morning and i'm
dumb still thank you but yes oh you're
dumb on friday thank you good i know but
so his fiance can the nfl hold them
responsible just be going that's an
unhealthy household and still make kyrie
kill an issue there go ahead those those
are the two violations
that that uh
that i think tyreek hill needs to be
concerned about one
did he threaten violence against crystal
espinal the very first item in the
personal conduct policy of the things
that are prohibited actual or threatened
physical violence and when you consider
the history when you consider that he
has made good on a threat of physical
violence against her in december of 2014
choked and beat her while she was
pregnant that looms over all this folks
because the nfl never had a chance to
suspend him for that yes he was drafted
in round five instead of round one
because of it but the nfl is going this
is human nature
anything you do with tyree kill that is
going to be not just at the back of your
mind that's going to be in the front of
your mind what he did in december of
2014. and for me chris look i gave the
guy the benefit of that i was like hey
he's changed he's matured he's grown
right i had him on the show last year i
it's like hey you know that was a
different guy that was a different time
that was a mistake that was a one-time
thing the moment i heard his voice while
they are debating he and crystal espinal
debating whether or not the boy respects
him or he's terrified of him right just
after a couple of steps when you need to
be terrified of me too that was chilling
that was cutting that was this guy from
december 2014 is still lurking in tyree
kill and that's when i concluded that
guy that guy we heard on that audio tape
is not fit to play in the nfl and that's
what i think he needs to worry about to
answer your other questions yeah right
any conduct that puts someone at any
type of danger or risk is a personal
conduct policy violation so if that
household is sufficiently unsafe the
state comes in and takes the kid out
how is that not a potential violation as
well he's looking at two violations with
aggravating circumstances from december
of 2014. chris i don't think he plays at
all this year i still don't think he
plays at all this year and let me throw
on top of that yeah the nfl's not gonna
want this guy on the field because it's
season 100 yeah and having him on the
field and having to talk about tyree
kill and the things he's done and the
things he's accused of doing and all the
issues relating to tyree kill takes away
from season 100 yeah no i i mean agreed
with you there it doesn't look good i'm
not rooting for tyree kill i could say
that and i mean it's it's it's you know
to what you said you're right last year
you're going okay you know this guy's
turned the corner he made a few mistakes
when he's young you talked about it
earlier in the show you and i we both
made a lot of dumb mistakes when we were
young but you know not not to that
extent i mean no there's mistakes and
then there's there's mistakes there's
the this was yes the crazy mistake that
he made but we still gave him the
benefit of the doubt he was still with
you know uh espanol here at this point
with their fiancee and moving forward so
you think okay things are going the
positive direction but this is egregious
it's horrible it's bad i don't know what
they're what more there is to say about
it you know and i don't know who
actually broke the three-year-old's arm
at home but obviously it's not a healthy
environment and he doesn't look good and
you're right i mean deserves to be
suspended i know that now whether it's
eight games a year whatever it may be is
going to be interesting to see what the
nfl actually does when all said and done
way too many chiefs fans taking that
comment from friday from the d.a and
assuming that tyreek hill should be back
right now it is not going to work that
way the nfl is not going to let it work
that way and i don't think the nfl
should let it work that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports